did you ever see the computer as like an
extension
of your mind like something able to
achieve not till later okay yeah no not
then it's just like a little set of
puzzles that you can play with and you
can you can play with math puzzles and
yeah it was it was too rudimentary early
on like it was sort of
yeah it was too it was a lot of work to
actually take a thought you'd have and
actually get it implemented and that's
still work but it's getting easier and
so yeah i would say that's definitely
what's attracted me to python is that
that was more real
right
i could think in python
speaking a foreign language i only speak
another language fluently besides
english which is spanish and i remember
the day when i would dream in spanish
and you start to think in that language
and then you actually i do definitely
believe that language
limits or expands your thinking
uh there are some languages that
actually lead you to certain
thought processes yeah like uh so i
speak russian fluently and that's
certainly uh
a language that leads you down certain
thoughts
well yeah i mean there's a um
there's a history of
the two world wars right of the
of millions of people starving to death
or near to death throughout his history
of suffering of injustice like this
promise sold to the people and then
the the carpet or whatever swept from
under them it's like broken promises and
all of that pain and melancholy is in
the language the sad songs the the sad
hopeful songs the over romanticized like
i love you i hate you the the sort of
the swings between all the various uh
spectrums of emotion so that's all
within the language the way it's twisted
uh poach there's a there's a there's a
strong culture of rhyming poetry so like
the bards like this this thing there's a
musicality to the language too did
dostoevsky write in russian
yeah so like
yes
all the uh
[Laughter]
all the the ones that i know about which
are translated and curious how the
translations so dostoevsky
did not use
the musicality of the language too much
so it actually translates pretty well
because it's so philosophically dense
that the story does a lot of the work
but there's a bunch of things that are
untranslatable certainly the poetry is
not translatable
i actually have a few
conversations coming up offline and also
in this podcast with people who've
translated dusty esky and that's in for
people who worked
who work in this field know how
difficult that is sometimes you can
spend
you know months thinking about a single
sentence right in in the context like
because there's just the magic captured
by that sentence and how do you
translate it just in the right way
because those words can be um
can be really powerful there's there's a
famous line
beauty will save the world from
dostoyevsky
you know there's so many ways to
translate that and you're right the
language gives you the tools with which
to tell the story but it also leads your
mind down certain trajectories and paths
to where over time as you think in that
language you become a different human
being yes yeah yeah that's a fascinating
reality i think that i know people have
explored that but it's
just rediscovered
well we don't we live in our own like
little pockets like this is the sad
thing
is
i feel like unfortunately given time and
given getting older i'll never know
the uh china the chinese world because i
don't truly know the language same with
japanese i don't really know japanese
and
portuguese and brazil that whole south
american continent like yeah i'll go to
brazil and argentina but will i truly
understand the people
if i don't understand the language it's
it's sad because um
i wonder how much how many geniuses were
missing because uh because so much of
the scientific world so much of the
technical world is in english
and so much of it might be lost because
they're they just we don't have the
common language i completely agree i'm
very much in that vein of
there's a lot of genius out there that
we miss and it's sort of sort of
fortunate when it when it bubbles up
into something that we can understand or
process there's a lot we miss
so i tend to lean towards really loving
uh democratization or things that
empower people or you know a
very resistant sort of authoritarian
structures
fundamentally for that reason
well several reasons but it just hurts
us yeah we're worse off
you